this week NASA released these posters
seeking recruits for a mission to Mars
the images hark back to the Space
Agency's golden age but look forward to
the new frontier they call for teachers
technicians surveyors and even farmers
to take part in the eventual exploration
of the red planet such posters mean more
today than they might have even just a
few years ago because there's a new
space race it could be titled
destination Mars NASA along with private
companies are planning expeditions to
the fourth planet from the Sun but these
astronaut explorers will all face the
same problem once they get there how do
they grow food so US scientists went to
the bone dry deserts of South America to
cook up a solution and Mark Albert is
here after traveling nearly 4,000 miles
for this story not exactly deep space
mark but it's good enough it's a story
you'll only see on CBS this morning
Saturday good morning mark good morning
and this is what mission accomplished
would look like space
spuds potatoes played a starring role in
one recent Hollywood film set on Mars
but it turns out growing potatoes on
another planet may be far from science
fiction this vast plane dotted with
dunes molded by centuries of unforgiving
wind and little rain is Mars on earth
the Pampas de la jolla desert in
southern Peru is harsh and arid as close
as it gets on our blue planet to the red
one next door these scientists are
trying to unearth the secret recipe for
farming on Mars hauling two tons of
sun-baked soil to their cosmic kitchen a
trip that takes two days so you brought
back a lot of dirt from the desert this
dirt is the main ingredient in an
audacious and groundbreaking test taking
place in Lima Peru is the very first
experiments that we're doing so we don't
really know how it's going to work out
and Yan Cruz II is essentially the head
chef for the project at the
International potato Center yes potato
can you grow potatoes on a planet that
died 2 billion years ago yes
to grow three years worth of food here
on a planet where nothing grows
Matt Damon sure pulled it off in the
2015 movie the Martian after
accidentally being stranded and with
dwindling supplies Damon's character a
botanist figures out how to grow
potatoes on Mars
in your face nice drama they don't have
a problem girl Rosa
thinks potatoes have the right stuff to
grow on the inhospitable Martian surface
why did you think potatoes of all things
would be a good fit well you know
potatoes are extremely versatile
extremely dry conditions in extremely
cold conditions where it reaches minus
20 at night then you can grow it from
like here we're in the tropics all the
way to above the Polar Circle you're
saying potatoes are very resilient yes
they are very resilient so they you can
grow them almost anywhere almost is the
key word and this is the soil from La
Joya desert we don't have anything
coming up here yet what does that mean
well it probably means that this soil is
not ideal for potato if you see the soil
it's it's almost like a it's it's very
dusty it's almost like a cement so when
we we water it becomes a very compact
and it might be a problem for the seeds
to push through that get oxygen in and
things like that when we visited this
Lima greenhouse last month
potato seeds planted an ideal earthly
soil had already sprouted so they did
well but after two weeks the seeds in
the martian like dirt failed to break
through the scientists found the seeds
didn't have room to breathe and the dirt
was simply too salty so they'll give the
next batch of seeds more space by
loosening up the soil as well as trying
other varieties of tubers that don't
mind a little extra salt in their diet
so it's trial and error it's trial and
error this is why we're doing these
experiments yes
crows II and his team have a lot of
options their Center is home to the
world's largest gene Bank of potatoes
four thousand varieties of potatoes and
eight thousand types of sweet potatoes
researchers have selected 65 for the
Mars experiment the laboratories have
over there dr. Julio Val diva Silva is
an astrobiologist working here for NASA
he envisions domed
climate controlled greenhouses on Mars
possibly even robots arriving before
humans to begin planting he says
shipping potatoes or any long-term food
supply with the astronauts is not viable
and it's too expensive
excess too expensive one kilogram is
about $10,000 in March
NASA tested its Mars rocket for the
first time the US Space Agency has
launched a program to land humans there
in about 15 years a confident Elon Musk
thinks his SpaceX startup can do it in
nearly half the time with its new Falcon
Heavy rocket should be able to launch
people probably in 2024 with arrival in
2025 the entrepreneur told The
Washington Post this month he is
ultimate goal is a self-sustaining city
on Mars and for that Musk's Martians
will need food later this summer crows
ax and his team will also try growing
potatoes in chambers that simulate the
harsh Martian atmosphere and if the
potatoes can survive that then they're
really hard
crows are also shared a confession when
he was a kid he really wanted to grow up
to be an astronaut he may not have
reached the heavens but his research
could provide mana to millions here on
earth where drought and climate change
in peril so many this isn't just about
Mars no it's not just about Mars we have
more earthly goals in mind
to improve livelihoods reduce hunger and
reduce malnutrition so it seems like a
big challenge it is a big challenge but
it's not impossible and and it's with
these big challenges that we we achieve
big things right
the researchers know they're on the
clock on Tuesday NASA will test what it
calls the largest most powerful booster
rocket in the world in the Utah desert
it will eventually carry astronauts and
perhaps those hearty potato seeds to
Mars
along with SpaceX other Mars projects
are in the works from Blue Origin Virgin
Galactic and Mars one fascinating just
fascinating if they can pull this off
that's gonna be one super sturdy spud
absolutely they're going to
some that are natural and some that have
been improved in the lab to see which
ones are more Hardy and which ones can
survive the atmosphere it's taste a
factor at all what they want it to taste
good that's not their top priority I
don't think survive yeah I suppose so
thank you very much mark